why are you dating what what is your end
goal from david so i have to ask this on
the day so if i'm on a first night what
day why are you dating somebody why are
you going on dates what is what do you
want from dating to meet someone i like
for what what what what's it what's the
loss of end game
husband
right yeah so you then have to when you
meet a guy you have to be explicit and
say to say to him i'm dating to be
married okay if he's not going to be
married he's wasting your [ __ ] time
so you're like how would you know that
from the philippines
but you don't guess you don't assume
you meet him in a bar you meet him
online
i am only dating to be married if you're
not on this you waste some let's not
just not waste money but when you say
like that kind of like scary yeah
that's what's gonna say it scares a lot
of us off but i don't want to be like
married like now like i'm saying like
could be like four to five years like
that's the end game
yeah fair relationship long term for
every four to five years if you don't if
not say if you're not explicit in your
and what you want as an outcome every
time you meet somebody you're just
drifting along
you might be around four or five years
so you wasted a year of someone that was
never interested in getting married to
anyone in the first place so if you're
not explicit about what you expect as an
outcome then how can outcomes you want
you need to be you say right this is
what i want
if you're not on this plan then there's
no point you join no point you talk to
me because this is what i want at the
end of it yeah but like guys in the
audience do you think it's a bit like a
bit overbearing so on the first day if
someone says to like oh like i want to
get married and someone has to kind of
like gauge if they want to get married
i didn't say you only get married i said
to you i'm dating to be mad i'm only
dating to be married but i think like
how can i marry you but i'm only dating
you
to be married but that's just a bit too
high i feel like it makes it puts a lot
of pressure no no but you're what you're
doing is filtering the guys who have no
intention of being married i guess it's
skilled for some people i would say like
even even mentioning like the word
married would freak them out and it
would freak me out if a guy was like
yeah i like i don't remember what does
dana go and he was like oh like he was
talking about like a proposal like on
the first date yeah it really freaked me
out
even though i was i had similar
intentions if you know what i mean i
would say like you know the first thing
you would say like oh like i'm trying to
get in a relationship and then you know
maybe a few days later you can be like
oh like do you ever oh there we go yeah
yeah yeah yeah um
oh like you know are you maybe like
looking to get married but you wouldn't
say it on the first date yeah that's not
really a first date i don't think it's a
discussion yeah i'm going to tell you
both you're very wrong and you're very
flawed and never really if that's what
you're wearing you're not going to get
we want our life you're going to go
through life just drifting
but so i mean
i'm telling you
men do get scared of the word i'm
telling you i feel like i think men also
have autonomy in like what's going on in
the relationship and i feel like the man
just like okay because the woman hasn't
said
explicitly that she wants to get married
that it's off the table i think a man
should be able to also make that
decision as well so i feel like just
saying putting the whole thing in the
woman's hand is probably not fair you're
missing something i'm not saying to you
you want to marry him i'm not saying
you're going to propose to him i'm just
going to make it clear for example i
don't want children right so whenever i
meet somebody i make absolutely [ __ ]
clear that it's not going to happen
if you want to date me knowing that
that's fine i mean
i respect that i respect that's the same
thing so if you know you want to be
married if not as to what you want out
of life then why are you dating guys
that doesn't want to be married
well i don't know but you don't know
because you don't tell them that's what
i want that's what you want
i guess do you think that's common
though i don't think it's like no i'm an
etiquette for a first date no no and i
just why you floss white women that's
why you float that's why no but i'm i'm
talking about let me finish
um
i'm talking about the people i know that
are married
most of like my uh my brother is
i would say going to get engaged this
year
he's 28.
yeah he's
like and the way like the he him and his
girlfriend just like met in college
dated for four or five years and like
now they bought a house probably gonna
get married
um and like same with my other brother
it was like the same thing
so i just like i don't know i'm not
saying you're wrong to be honest because
i actually like agree with you on some
level
but
generation
don't try it don't try she's on you
she's on youtube don't try it
she's landing a couple
what would i say in response to that is
this um
so how would you react if someone said
like i want to get my intention is to
marry on the first date like how would
everyone react to that because i feel
like that's what hey
what are you doing
how's your response
where'd you go from that time in a place
you would say
[Music]
and like this guy he never mentioned
married but he was like oh yeah like i'm
trying to like travel the world with my
significant other i'm like
i'm like i don't know you like why
like what yeah
now for me it's like
a time in the place is not necessarily i
take it as face value what i mean by
that is
if someone tells you it comes up to me
you know like wait on the thursday and
says oh i'm dating to get married cool a
big turnover personally for me is when a
woman knows like what she wants so if i
tell you time in the place i really mean
it's like look i'm looking to get
married in the next this amount of time
i'm looking to do it like this i want
this like i will know what i want out of
this out of a relationship and stuff
like that that's a really big turnout
for me personally turn off or turn up
turn on
you know what you want out of this
relationship i know what i wanna when i
go into a relationship i know what i
want i want you know i wanna i wanna
date i wanna you know have someone to
come back home to you to marry to love
to have kids to build a family in the
next
eight years
right but i know that right and when a
woman comes along with the same energy
that is just a really big plus
i guess it can work out really well if
you're both on the same level so if the
person also has like that same intent
and he's very forward as well then i
think it makes a lot of sense but i just
don't think in the uk we have that kind
of culture to be that forward so it just
comes across a bit
a bit strange actually so that's nice so
you want to be married you want to be
married at some point not a married man
but like in a very committed
relationship
what yeah i want to get married
time in the place
time and place before
before
yeah
do you have a time and place in mind it
is eight years i wasn't saying did you
you just described it
look
when i first started thinking about it i
was like like very young yeah but like
my me and my friend was like just like
just joking around and i said i was like
i want to be
have a kid when married like bef so when
my kid is born i can still be the you
know the cool dad
you know someone that you're that you
know i don't want to be that guy that's
like oh dad let's go throw a ball and
i'm and i'm like oh rusty like walking
around like
like it's this bad thing no i don't want
that you want to be able to play i want
to be i want to be active i want to you
know pick my son up and like outrun him
in a race and be man then talk [ __ ] to
him when he's young you know i want to
be that dad i don't want to be that dad
that sits on the couch all day drinking
beer and watching tv no that's not no
[ __ ] speaking facts
such a vivid picture so the ladies do
any of you have like friends in their
30s yes
yeah i don't think i do they're friends
and authorities that are unmarried but
would like to have been married already
or want to be married um
[Music]
so far i mean so far i don't really know
i think they want to have kids but they
don't necessarily want to get married
they're more like they've gone past that
point
i mean i don't know
yeah we haven't really had that
discussion but i mean she's single and
she's dating
like or like in kind of like talking to
someone you know like whatever that's
someone but there's like a marriage
inflation with our generation like i
feel like every generation seems to get
married later and settle down a bit
later so i feel like we need to like
like i should face that in mind and
probably not want to get married so
early i think before 30 might be a bit
too much optimistic actually i think it
flawed first i think i think your
opinion on that is flawed okay